you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
if I asked you to name some colors or
the color of a banana you'd tell me a
banana is yellow right well this is like
weird really when you think about it I
don't know about your house but in my
house the bananas are green when we buy
them and then they spend you know a day
being yellow and then they're like brown
spotted and eventually black things
before we throw them out so in their
whole lifespan they've spent very little
time of their lives being yellow but
this is the color we encode it's the
color we think of and in fact it's so
strong that it's the color we project
onto the world around us so color we
know is not simply the light hitting our
eyes because there's all of these where
we can think of as cognitive influences
that shape what experience out there my
current favorite example of the
interaction between art practice and the
neuroscience of color is really a close
reading of Matisse in many of his
finished canvases he actually leaves
these little white bits of unpainted
canvas between painted marks and it's a
discovery he made because by introducing
this little white buffer you protect
from color contrast color induction you
protect the colored marks so that they
remain about the same in the finished
painting as they were when he first made
them so as he's painting in the studio
and he wants his Apple to stay that
color he can paint the background lots
of other colors and have the Apple still
stay that color by just not painting
next to it just leaving a little bit of
white around it so color contrast is the
simple phenomenon that is when you when
you paint a mark the color of the
painted mark changes as you paint the
background around the mark and this is a
problem that new artists struggle with
old artists struggle with and that's
because the color of the background
unconsciously is changing the way in
which the color of the foreground
appears and we our brains do this
effortlessly and unconsciously so much
so that you don't even think about the
impact of the surround in shaping your
experience of the object color that
you're attending to and that discovery
is it were by Matisse I think came about
because of you know his struggle in the
studio working with paint working with a
visual system that has particular
constraints on the way in which it
computes light information to generate
color and the consequence in art history
is that you know it changed forever how
we think about art how we think about
paint how we think about what paintings
are we see that legacy in Rothko we're
now he's gotten rid of everything except
paint and canvas just large fields of
color at the time that Matisse was
working that would have been considered
completely like crazy I mean like
literally everything like nude I don't
know what that is
so you see you know the impact of these
choices on art practice the impact those
choices make on the trajectory of our
tradition Western art history tradition
but they also in this wonderful way
produce this other discovery which is
that color is divorced from shape so
Matisse shows us and then is extended
through Rothko shows us that you can
take color completely out of shape right
the bananas color doesn't have to be
attached to the banana
can have a field of yellow and you can
have a shape of a banana and the fact
that we experience those things as
together happens because of probably
something statistical about their Co
occurrence in the world not because of
something fundamental about their yoking
in our brains because if they were
fundamentally yoked in our brains we
would never be able to see the Rothko as
a field of red divorced from shape
[Music]
you
[Music]